DC extended universe fans rejoice Warner
Brothers just dropped a new poster
promoting the forthcoming Wonder Woman
1984 film and the visual content is
rather revealing Wonder Woman 1984 is
the follow-up to 2017 s Wonder Woman one
of the better received entries and
Warner Brothers mostly troubled attempt
to contend with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe considering the popularity of
the original film and its leading lady
fans have been eager to devour this
sequel since it was announced back in
2018
sadly Wonder Woman 1984 has had a pretty
tortured path to the big screen since
that announcement Warner Brothers
originally slated Wonder Woman 1984 for
a December 2019 release then pushed that
date up to November 2019 then to June
2020 it just wasn't fair to fans and
then it got even worse to be fair
Wonder Woman 1984 was recently delayed
again though only by a few months the
film is still slated for a summer
release August 14th 2020 to be precise
Warner Brothers must be pretty committed
to this ambitious new date because the
studio has already started pulling out
the big promotional guns releasing a new
poster that reveals some important
information if we're being honest with
ourselves any new poster featuring gal
gadot as Wonder Woman seems like a
newsworthy development but this one has
elevated significance the latest art
from the film is a kaleidoscopic blast
of color centered on Godot in her golden
eagle armor the battle suit first
debuted in the third issue of Elseworlds
Kingdom Come a short Wonder Woman and
Superman crossover comic story from
creators Alex Ross and Mark Waid that DC
ran in 1996
unlike Wonder Woman 1984 Kingdom Come
takes place in the near future and
concerns the original Justice League's
efforts to thwart a new generation of
metahumans that pursue the superhero
trade through violent means it's in the
middle of this conflict that Wonder
Woman busts out her new golden threads
since Kingdom Come many other Wonder
Woman's stories have featured the Golden
Eagle armor including Wonder Woman
number 144 our worlds at war and rise of
an Olympian will we see some elements
from these popular comic arcs adapted
into the future film only time will tell
given the film's 1984 setting its plot
likely won't address any of the
cliffhangers set up by 2017 s Justice
League but it still promises to be an
entertaining wrap full of action humor
and heart have you ever been in love a
long long time ago yeah so many times
yeah all the time aside from the new
look the most important piece of
information on the poster is the
confirmation that Warner Brothers plans
to forge ahead with Wonder Woman 1984 is
late summer release date this is quite
the scheduling flex since the sequel
flick could be pushed back yet again
depending on when it's safe to return to
movie theaters it would be pretty hard
to imagine Warner Brothers letting such
an important and expensive film play two
empty seats
for now we can at least appreciate the
studio's optimism fans who have already
been burned twice before by thwarted
release dates for Wonder Woman 1984
await the new August drop with cautious
optimism many other big films have been
delayed this year including the latest
James Bond flick the live-action lawn
movie and the New Mutants none of those
projects have dared to cement a summer
theatrical release in writing let alone
in expensive marketing materials
alongside Godot --tz-- Diana Prince
Warner Brothers has already confirmed
that Wonder Woman 1984 will feature the
return of Chris Pines Steve Trevor
though just how that will be possible
within the DCE use internal logic has
been a topic of heated debate as you'll
remember Steve seemingly died at the end
of the first Wonder Woman movie also
confirmed as Kristen Wiig who will
portray the villainous cheetah and Pedro
Pascal as Maxwell Lord although neither
wig nor Pascal is featured in the latest
poster for Wonder Woman 1984 fans are
equally eager to see how they bring
their characters to the screen with any
luck we'll find out by August 14th check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you